uh Brendan real quick I have to ask you  I'm a big fan of Todd Phillips and what  he did on Joker I know that you signed  on for the sequel  um what was it about the material that  said I want to be in this movie uh it  wasn't the material which is a great way  of getting me out of having to answer  any questions about the material which I  can't yeah it was it was you know it was  the achievement about the first film it  was like walking I worked I worked with  Joaquin before on the village oh yeah  yeah and so I knew I knew him from then  uh and I that performance I'm still in  awe of it that performance as Joker in  that first movie and it was one of the  most extraordinary achievements I've  ever had on for Todd to have amazed you  know worst movie around to allow for  that I didn't have to be asked twice I  really didn't